5 53 on your wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy imagine
completely rebuilding i-15
at tropicana well not only is the nevada
department of transportation imagining
it
they're getting ready to do it lynette
russell from ndot gave a virtual
presentation to the clark county
commission yesterday and it was an
eye-opener
here are just two of the many things she
talked about
one get ready to say goodbye to the ramp
from the south 15 to eastbound drop
the department will need to replace the
existing flyover you can see here the
flyover is in a slightly different
location
they're also planning to put in overhead
signs like they did on project neon
technically they're known as active
traffic management signs or atms the atm
infrastructure will enhance safety
provide real-time information to drivers
and provide an opportunity to actively
manage the freeway corridor
now there is way more to unpack than we
have time for here so i encourage you to
visit our website to check out her
entire presentation about 20 minutes
long
bottom line construction might start
next year if it does it'd be scheduled
to be a mess until the end of 2024.
we'll certainly keep you posted buckle
up drive carefully and please put down
that phone
if there's something that's driving you
crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com